la palestine n'est pas à vendre et le
plan trump ne passera jamais des
dizaines de pancartes barrées de ses
slogans ont vu le jour en cisjordanie
parmi les événements marquants un grand
rassemblement à jéricho en présence de
nombreux diplomates qui se sont succédé
à la tribune un message fort pour les
palestiniens qui attendent aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus que des mots
c'est un plan qui s'opposent aux doigts
d'un manteau des palestiniens c'est
pourquoi nous nous mobilisons vous voyez
ici nous sommes des milliers de tout le
territoire et de toutes les tendances
politiques
c'est encourageant de voir que beaucoup
nous soutiennent aussi l'union
européenne l'onu la russie le japon la
chine
tous ces pays considèrent que nous avons
des droits légitimes au regard du droit
international
nous ne souhaitons pas la destruction
d'israël mais uniquement que l'on
respecte nos droits jéricho est la
capitale de la vallée du jourdain
plaines fertiles qu israël souhaite
notamment annexée sur ses terres la
plupart des agriculteurs cultivent les
dates et le raisin des produits pour
moitié destinée au marché local et pour
l'autre revendu à l'international ismail
ayed promet de défendre les territoires
palestiniens jusqu au bout on ne partira
pas même si je dois mourir je ne
partirai pas même si je dois manger de
la terre je ne partirai pas on a laissé
notre terre une fois en 48 on ne va pas
le refaire
personne ne va partir
même si un petit boulot on va creuser
des folies avec nos mains ismaila y est
comme beaucoup d'autres gardent espoir
et se bat malgré 53 ans d'occupation de
la cisjordanie par israël depuis les
colonies israéliennes s'étendent des
colonies pourtant illégales selon le
droit international
[Musique]